I know I know I know you don't have to
tell me I shouldn't be going to bars
picking fights with people I know but
you should have saw the other guy no I
did not get punched this is poison ivy I
get it four times a year I just had a
dream last night I was dreaming like wow
I didn't get poison ivy this year then I
wake up with this it sucks because I
have to do videos and I do videos every
day and but I just deed you know what
I'm just going to do a video anyway and
I'll I'll talk a little bit about what
happened to me with uh years of prazone
and uh also we'll talk about cortisol as
it relates to stress and is it possible
that you could end up with the side
effects from predis Zone by going
through chronic stress we're going to
talk about that this is hideous maybe I
should talk to you like this it's a
little bit no that's not even I I can't
even look at this I'm just going to wear
these I don't even want to want you to
look at it looks disgusting but this
looks better so let's talk about prazone
and cortisol but let me just tell you a
quick story about what happened to me in
my 20s I was gardening and somehow there
was some poison I in there and I got
exposed to it and I reacted really bad
go to the doctor take the prazone it
goes away next year same thing happens
this went on for like probably 10 years
in a row until the point where my poison
ivy reactions on my skin didn't go away
so I couldn't use prazone anymore and I
know from that prazone it created a lot
of problems with my body which I'm going
to talk about but it's pretty scary if
you have some type of severe
inflammatory skin reaction or other
reactions and you need something to help
and prazone doesn't work what do you do
but a very unfortunately it's I have not
figured this poison ivy out in fact I
don't even have to touch poison ivy I
could get close to it I could get maybe
a few feet away from it and all of a
sudden I'll start getting reactions so
it must be in my nervous system because
because these similar patterns of poison
ivy itching start to pop out in certain
places rarely on my face but this time
it was on my eye which really sucks
because now I have to wait for like two
weeks before it goes away so why do
people take prazone mainly or an
anti-inflammatory or some type of immune
supressant effect so they give it to
people with autoimmune diseases
arthritis injuries and even uh if you
have an organ transplant it's part of
the immune suppressive effects because
the immune system will start attacking
the new organ that was put in you now
the problem with this prazone it comes
with a package it gives you side effects
if you take higher doses I think like 80
milligrams you could start getting a
moon face but I think a lot of people
have a subclinical version of this not
even taking prazone just by high levels
of cortisol and they start developing
somewhat of a round moon face in fact I
had it when I was under a lot of carbs
there is a big association between a
condition called Cushing syndrome where
you have this high level cortisol uh and
uh also Diabetes Type 2 metabolic
syndrome polycystic ovarian syndrome
things like that a lot of things that
are unknown but just realize that
prazone is a synthetic version of
cortisol and cortisol um is a hormone in
the adrenal glands that actually helps
your immune system it does a lot It
prepares the body for stress situations
so to better understand this I'll show
you in this medical book right here okay
right here a condition called pushings
syndrome which the person has high
levels of cortisol and the fat is
redistributed to their face their belly
and like on the top of their shoulders
like a hunchback they get a fat pad
there and the body is literally
taking protein from certain places and
turning that into sugar and converting
into fat from the thighs the butt so you
lose your butt you lose your legs and it
goes right to the belly and there's a
lot of problems because you get rosacea
spider veins osteoporosis you lose
potassium calcium magnesium you also
deplete or block vitamin D's effect so
you don't get the vitamin D effect which
is interesting allergies asthma immune
suppression so you're more susceptible
to viruses heartburn as well as diabetes
because the body's turning its own self
protein into sugar at a massive level so
you can end up with diabetes so that was
Cushing syndrome but I think there is a
subclinical situation going around with
people because you don't just end up
with that overnight it's kind of a
gradual slow process with this high
level of cortisol over period of time so
you might have some of those symptoms
because of stress now if you look at the
cause of Cushing syndrome um you know
they talk about genetics they talk about
a tumor on the adrenal gland or maybe a
tumor on your pituitary gland which by
the way if you have a tumor on the
pituitary gland um you'll have also like
a hyperpigmentation your skin will be
darker but also Cushing syndrome can
occur with animals you know they can
have tumors and they can create these
problems but here's the thing prazone
can also create pushing syndrome and all
of those effects so pregnazon comes with
a package you're 10 times more likely to
get high blood glucose diabetes you get
heart problems arhythmia problems
palpitation even Strokes psychosis you
can have all sorts of mental side
effects you become highly irritable
usually with the lower doses but then
when you get higher doses you can get
depression you crave sugar and salt and
you retain fluids which makes sense from
several things but um you know you have
to realize if you're getting this
adrenal stimulation it's not just
cortisol that's being affected you have
other hormones in the adrenals that
control your fluid balance as well but
realize that cortisol itself is a
glucocorticoid so basically cortisol can
affect glucose in a big way it gets your
body to run on glucose it messes up
glucose metabolism so you can't deal
with glucose sugar very well anymore
this is why stress is one of the big
causes of insulin resistance and so does
prazone cause the side effect of insulin
resistance and diabetes so it's
interesting because a lot of the effects
of sugar are similar to the effects of
stress this is why you can get off sugar
but go through stress and your body will
start to uh act like you're eating sugar
a couple things you need to know about
prazone is that once you start taking it
you don't want to come off of it too
fast get with your doctor to make sure
you do it gradually because you can have
more side effects because when you take
uh prosome uh the body now depends on
that and it stops producing its own
cortisol and so if you come off of it
too quickly and the adrenals can't
produce that I mean you can imagine the
side effects um because it just doesn't
bounce back right away for everyone and
then sometimes people come off of it and
now they get those symptoms that come
right back so that's really the Catch 22
with this prazone is that okay it gets
rid of your inflammatory conditions and
your symptoms but then you're going to
come off what's going to keep them gone
you really can't be on this prazone
forever and the more you take it the
more it weakens the system but if you
don't take it you have the symptoms come
back so it's really a situation also if
you're on a prazone realize that uh it
depletes a lot of nutrients calcium
magnesium potassium zinc B vitamins
vitamin C chromium
um there's a really great pharmacist who
uh basically has a whole Channel about
prazone I'm going to put that link down
below she has some great information but
the point is that prazone and cortisol
deplete you of nutrients so if someone
is on prazone they should also be taking
these nutrients and also especially as
they come off prazone and that way
they'll have less complications
hopefully so whether you're on prazone
or whether you're going through chronic
stress let's talk about how to reduce
cortisol the number one thing is to do
whatever you can to lower your stress
wherever that's coming from is it coming
from people is it coming from videos
that you're watching that give you bad
news like anything that's causing the
stress you just have to deal with that
the other thing that you can do and I
released a couple videos on this topic
um a lot of times when you have this
sustained chronic uh mental stress the
body doesn't know the difference between
the physical stress and mental stress so
being chased by a tiger could be
equivalent to going through this chronic
stress to some level so I think a good
way to counter that is to do uh physical
work exercise of course long walks
especially in nature would be good uh
also there's some great data on um
certain Hobbies like in the Arts or even
music huge benefit to lower cortisol and
stress because it shifts your attention
off the worry and worrying is the worst
form of stress because you're you're not
solving any problems you're just
thinking about them and you're stirring
up the problems so the more that you can
get your mind off of it and focus on
something else the better from a
nutrition angle
magnesium
potassium and B1 and uh vitamin D almost
forgot about vitamin D and uh I should
mention this too I forgot one of the
side effects of prazone is a loss of
cognitive function memory Focus brain
fog another thing that is really good
for U lowering cortisol is ashwagandha
there's other adapted gens but
ashwaganda is really really good and
then the next thing you could do is just
focus on your breathing your breathing
can put you in a state of
relaxation calmness it can help lower
cortisol by slowing the breath down uh I
have videos on this but if you could
slow your breath down to six breaths per
minute that's like 5 seconds in 5
seconds out um and you control it it can
help pull you out of a panic attack it
can help you sleep it can help reduce
cortisol and there's a really cool thing
we're going to be coming out with and uh
we might have that out already so check
in the description but it's a device
okay that we're not really looking at
the oxygen we're looking at your pulse
rate there's data that we can extract
off the pulse rate and there's a
technology called heart rate variability
that measures this uh stress and
Recovery cycle because that way you can
kind of see where you're at you can't
really improve something if you can't
measure it so this is a very good
objective and visual way of looking
inside your body and seeing where you're
really at with your stress and Recovery
your ability to adapt this stress and uh
it's a really cool technology so I will
um put that link down below when I'm
ready to release that but if you want
the complete list of all 25 ways to
lower cortisol I have a link for that
press the link down below you go to my
website download it for free and start
applying this information for your own
stress